there won't be a recovery unless we
reopen schools now if children can't go
to school parents can't go to work we're
told schools must be closed to keep kids
safe but they're not in danger according
to CDC data children under 18 make up
only 2% of cases and not 0.6% of
hospitalizations children under 14
makeup just naught point naught 2
percent of deaths now the media
misinformation machine is fear-mongering
about a new mystery disease that affects
children dr. foutch recited this when
pushing back on Rand Paul's demand to
reopen schools this year but we're
talking about a handful of cases which
are almost always treatable how
offensive to try and frighten parents
about the safety of their children a
more serious argument for school
closures is that wealth children may not
get sick themselves they can infect
others do they we're constantly told to
follow the science and their data well
here it is one study found quote even if
children do get infected they are less
likely to transmit the disease to others
than adults we have not found a single
instance of a child infecting parents
they lecture us about contact tracing
while they did it for a boy with
coronavirus they found that even though
he came into contact with a hundred and
seventy two classmates and teachers
while symptomatic he didn't transmit the
disease to any of them not one out of a
hundred and seventy two people in
Switzerland the country's head of
infectious disease says scientists quote
now know young children don't transmit
the virus and because of all this France
Israel Germany Greece Portugal South
Korea and many other countries have
already begun letting their children
back into schools
two weeks after Denmark reopened their
schools a scientist in the Department of
infectious diseases at Aarhus University
said there are no signs whatsoever that
the partial reopening has caused a
bigger spread of infection yet still the
schools here are closed even in states
where bars and restaurants are reopening
we're in all this is our own CDC by the
way why do we have to rely on scientist
from Switzerland Denmark Iceland yet
another reason for the bungler in chief
useless dr. Robert Redfield to go
meanwhile the mental health toll on
children grows by the day as does the
loss of learning all of it hurting the
poorest areas most especially those in
remote parts of the country with
unreliable internet and the poorest
families any leader anywhere in America
who is not planning to reopen schools
now not in the next few months not in
the fall but now is a data denier and a
science denier get on with it and reopen
schools now before you do even more
needless damage but once we reopen
schools and businesses we can't have
stupid regulations stifling the recovery
masks fine
but what's this unscientific nonsense
about compulsory temperature checks
totally pointless
you'll miss most people with coronavirus
and catch many who don't have it these
completely arbitrary social distancing
rules 25 percent occupancy 33 percent
50%
what's it even based on only one or two
people allowed in an elevator at one
time good luck trying to reopen New York
like that or any downtown business
district frankly this over prescriptive
regulation is typical of the
infantilizing mindset of our
technocratic ruling elite if you boss
people around with arbitrary rules
they'll resist but ask people to behave
responsibly with common sense and they
will that's also why liability
protection for employers who do the
right thing is an essential part of any
recovery package next point and this
unjustified climate of fear thanks to
media misinformation
too many Americans wrongly fear they're
at risk from this virus that's a
disaster for the recovery because it
stops people getting back to real life
obviously the best way to reduce public
fear is a vaccine and effective
treatment in the Trump administration
has done incredible work to speed up
progress on both but we urgently need
the federal government perhaps even the
wretched CDC can do something useful for
a change
to mount a scientific data-driven
information campaign to explain to
Americans how low the risks really are
for most people two more things the
shutdown is decimating countless
businesses even whole industries people
might be getting ready to go back to a
job that doesn't exist anymore we've
been a strong advocate of skills
training on this show and we've
championed Ivanka Trump's efforts to
give our workers the tools they need to
succeed in the 21st century her work now
will be even more important for the
recovery especially if it's accompanied
by a huge new loan program to help
people transition from unemployment to
start their own business that really
would be a transition to greatness and
I'll just end with this thought one of
the things I'm most proud of in my
career is helping to set up National
Citizen Service in the UK kind of
non-military national service I think
something like that could make a huge
difference here in America right now
people are looking for ways to help and
with the huge unemployment numbers this
would be a great way to bring the
country together and unite people of
different backgrounds it would help in
this moment but would also be a
fantastic
legacy for the future